volvemos con información de economía
aquí en france 24 y saludamos a nuestro
periodista luís méndez quien nos va a
contar lo más importante hoy louis y
empezamos hablando de eeuu porque el
país logró aprobar un acuerdo para el
presupuesto nacional así de siliana en
esto luego que la cámara de
representantes aprobara un marco
presupuestario que abre el camino para
impulsar el paquete económico del
presidente yo bailé el presupuesto es de
3.5 millones de dólares que podría
generar grandes cambios en la salud
educación e impuestos de eeuu los fondos
serían gestionados en un incremento en
los impuestos a las grandes empresas que
pasa del 21 al 28 por ciento la
discusión que se retrasó por varios días
tuvo un grupo de demócratas que buscaban
priorizar un plan inicial de 1.2
millones de dólares para invertir en
carreteras redes transporte y acceso a
internet pero escuchemos lo que es el
presidente yo baires respecto a la
manera en la que serán invertidos los
recursos
dark days bout en house la agenda a
reconstruir mejor es un marco amplio
para hacer que la vivienda sea más
asequible reducir el costo de los
medicamentos recetados al darle a
medicare el poder de negociar precios
más bajos para los medicamentos hacer
que la atención de las personas mayores
sea más asequible
brindar dos años de servicios gratuitos
universales y de alta calidad break
inter y dos años de colegio comunitario
gratuitos mary college louis continuamos
en eeuu porque todo está listo para el
comienzo del simposio de política
económica de jackson hole es un evento
organizado por el banco de la reserva
federal de kansas city y se entrará su
temática este año en la política
macroeconómica dentro de una economía
desigual debido a la situación del cobi
19 el simposio se llevará a cabo de
manera virtual esta reunión que agrupa a
una serie de autoridades bancos
centrales y personalidades ligadas a la
economía se lleva a cabo desde 1978 por
el momento la atención estará centrada
en la jornada del viernes cuando sea el
presidente de la reserva federal
estadounidense llega un power que
ofrezca su perspectiva del panorama
financiero internacional
diversos analistas coinciden que powell
ofrecerá detalles respecto al retiro del
estímulos monetarios
hablamos ahora de brasil porque es
ofrecido en datos de inflación por
anticipado estamos en este momento
hablando del índice de precios al
consumidor donde las autoridades tomaron
el periodo comprendido entre la segunda
quincena de julio y la primera del mes
de agosto el informe ofrecido por el
instituto brasileño de estadística y
geografía y que proyecta la inflación
para el medio agosto se ubicó en 0 89% a
nivel mensual este dato se muestra como
la mayor variación del registro para un
mes de agosto en los últimos 20 años en
lo que va de año la inflación se ha
incrementado 5 31 por ciento y en los
últimos 12 meses el alza alcanza los 93
por ciento en este sentido el ministro
de economía de brasil paulo pérez
anunció que no descarta superar el techo
de gasto para inicios del próximo año
esta noticia se presenta un día después
de que el presidente de brasil que ha
evolucionado
saville hizo a los gobernadores por el
aumento de precio en algunos productos
bueno lo hice en el salvador de anunciar
muchas empresas que no cumplan con el
aumento salarial es una medida que entró
en vigor el primero de agosto y las
autoridades detallaron que 35 empresas
del sector comercio e industria serán
multadas por incumplir la medida el
ministro del trabajo fijó una sanción de
57 dólares por cada trabajador vulnerado
en este sentido algunas empresas podrían
pagar hasta 179 mil dólares por no
ajustarse a la normativa en ese país de
centroamérica existen 800 52 mil
empresas que deben aplicar el incremento
salarial de acuerdo con la inspección
gubernamental con el aumento salarial
por ejemplo los trabajadores del sector
comercio y servicios pasaron de ganar
300 417 dólares ahora a 365 dólares en
alemania louis continúa sumando los
daños las inundaciones recientes la
cifra puede ser mayor a los 8 mil 200
millones de dólares solamente en daños
esto de acuerdo con la asociación
alemana de seguros ella especifica que
los daños en edificios residenciales
equipos
y empresas representan 7 mil 600
millones de dólares mientras que los
daños a vehículos representaron otros
529 millones en alemania casi todos los
edificios residenciales están asegurados
contra tormentas y granizo pero sólo un
46% de estos tiene seguro de peligros
adicionales como lluvias e inundaciones
hay que recordar que el gobierno alemán
ya anunció que podría dar hasta 35 mil
millones de dólares para ayudar a la
reconstrucción de las zonas afectadas es
el mismo la información de economía y
ustedes gracias continúen con más
central 24 punto com
[Música]